so one of the great cowards in america
in public life is seth rogen so seth
rogen of course
is the director of wide variety of i
would say mediocre to
somewhat good films he's done a couple
of things that are kind of interesting
um
he's also a wildly overrated actor a
jerk on on social media by the way
but where he's really a jerk is when it
comes to his friends so james franco
was a longtime friend of seth rogen and
rogan defended him over and over he made
jokes
open jokes about seth rogen about james
franco's proclivity for
17 year old girls and um and recently he
came out
i'm not gonna make any movies with james
anymore just not gonna do it anymore oh
yes i'm sure it came as a great shock to
you to learn that james franco
was actually james franco so seth rogen
because he's a coward he threw james
franco directly under the bus now he's
saying you know what i love canceled
culture canceled culture is just the
best
and comedians who worry about cancer
culture you know comedians who get upset
that they're getting canceled overall
jokes they just shut up because times
change man
and we just have to recognize that some
of our old jokes were bad
seth rogen has realized that that the
gold in hollywood is if you lead the mob
then the mob won't eat you so if they
ever criticize you about no choking you
know you're right
i was homophobic that was that was a
truly homophobic joke he's been doing
this for for years by the way
all the way back in 2016 he started
ripping on
his own movie super bad he said that
some of the riffs in the
movie quote border on blatantly
homophobic
he said it's funny looking at some
movies we've made in the last 10 years
under the lenses of new eras new social
consciousness
there's for sure some stuff in our
earlier earlier movies and even our
in our most recent movies or even a year
later you're like maybe that wasn't the
greatest idea well now he's carrying
that forward on good morning britney
says i don't even know why people are
against canceled culture i don't even
understand why cancellation's bad
because
after all you know times change saying
terrible things is bad so if you said
something terrible then
that's something you should confront in
some way shape or form um i don't think
that's cancel culture
that's you saying something terrible if
if that's what you've done
now here's the beauty of being seth
rogen you get to say what is the
terrible thing
right that's the beauty of it if
somebody says you said something
terrible you go
yeah sure i did say something terrible
but here's the thing i know that i said
something terrible
everybody else out there they're the
ones who are really saying terrible
things
those are the ones who are really saying
terrible things now seth rogen thinks
this is going to protect him
it is not going to protect him there
will come a point in which you finally
stumble on a core value that seth rogen
holds see to believe in the constantly
shifting
line here you have to have no core
values you have to essentially be an
ideological
nihilist you have to think that the
values of society
constantly moving ever shifting there
are no there's no core to it
so if you said something that apparently
everything in the past is up for debate
everything he has ever said he can just
disown as
indefensible a year later he'll just
move right along
which means that he's a coward and
gutless because if you have any core
principles at all
at a certain point you say you know what
yeah it was a funny joke and if you find
it offensive right now
gotta say tough so anyone with an iota
of actual credibility would say
when you just skate along on the surface
of life disowning
all of your prior statements as
statements of the moment
without demonstrating why exactly you
think they were bad or what has changed
in your mind about it
this makes you just a tool of people who
are who are seeking to destroy other
people's careers
so if you're friends with seth rogen
don't look for that guy to stand in
front of a train for you he ain't gonna
do it
if you're anybody in the comedic
community who's friends with seth rogen
just understand that when they come for
you
seth rogen is gonna immediately turn
around and engage in some friendly fire
because that's his top priority his top
priority is moving along with the crowd
and fomenting the crowd and fomenting
the mob
now what's funny about this is that
eventually cancel culture does hit
everybody
eventually everybody gets canceled so
there's this woman named emily wilder
she was hired at the ap and emily wilder
had a long history of sort of bizarre
statements online uh she had called me
a little turd or something i don't care
that that's the mildest of the
criticism i received online but mostly
she had been associated with a wild
left anti-israel group called students
for justice in palestine
which is in fact a radical anti-israel
and in many cases de facto pro-terrorist
group and that came out
and the ap decided that they didn't want
to hire her anymore and i said
on this show just a few days ago i
didn't think that they should not hire
her i think that's what the ap is and
they should own it
she came out with a video immediately
saying well you know it's because of
people like ben
shapiro that this happened well no it
really wasn't
i just pointed out that emily wilder has
also spoken openly
about how when people on the right get
canceled that's not cancel culture
that's accountability culture but when
she gets canceled
that's not accountability that's
cancelled culture
but here is the thing when the cancel
culture comes
for seth rogen then
is he going to call it accountability
culture i really doubt it the way this
works is that folks
who are on the the hardcore cancel
culture left they're not interested in
the overton window being open
they're interested in it being closed so
long as they get to control the overtone
window
the the ironic part of this is that
eventually it comes for everybody
eventually the alligator eats you
because the mob always needs fresh
bodies the mob
always needs people that it can that it
can bury
and you can try to appease them and try
to run away from them or at some point
you might have to have some core values
so i wonder how long it'll be before
they reach a core value of seth rogens
in which he tries to defend himself and
he's finished too
when that happens guess what ain't gonna
have a lot of defenders out here
because if you are the person swinging
the frying pan at all of your heretofore
friends
and then it comes back and hits you in
the face we just call that poetic
justice
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe